do you think there's
some number or perhaps a very very large
number
of uh intelligent alien civilizations
out there
yes would be hard to think otherwise i
know i think bostrom
had a new article not that long ago on
why that might not be the case that
the drake equation might not be the kind
of in story on it
but when i look at the total number of
kepler planets just
that we're aware of just galactically
and and also
like when that um when those life forms
were discovered in mono lake
that didn't have the same six primary
atoms i think it had arsenic replacing
phosphorus as one of the
primary aspects of its energy metabolism
we get to think about that the building
blocks might be
more different so the physical
constraints even the planets have to
have might be more different
it seems really unlikely not not to
mention
interesting things that we've observed
that are still unexplained
as you've had guests on your show
discussing tic tac and
oh oh the ones that have visited yeah
well let's dive right into that
what do you make sense of uh the rich
human psychology of uh there being
hundreds of thousands probably millions
of witnesses of ufos of different kinds
on earth
most of which i presume are conjured up
by the human mind
through the perception system some
number
might be true some number might be
reflective of
actual physical objects whether it's uh
you know drones or testing military
technology that's secret or otherworldly
technology
we make sense of all that because it's
gained quite a bit of popularity
recently
there's uh some sense in which that's um
that's us humans being hopeful and
dreaming
of otherworldly creatures
as a way to escape the dreariness of our
of the human condition but in another
sense it could be
it really could be something truly
exciting that a science should
turn its eye towards so what do you
where do you place it speaking of
turning eye towards this is one of those
super fascinating actually super
consequential possibly
topics that i wish i had more time to
study and just haven't allocated so i
i don't have firm beliefs on this
because i haven't got to study it as
much as i want so
what i'm going to say comes from a
superficial assessment
um while we know there are plenty of
things that people thought of as ufo
sightings that we can fully
write off we have other better
explanations for them
uh what we're interested in is the ones
that we don't have better explanations
for and then not just immediately
jumping to
uh a theory of what it is but holding it
as unidentified and being
being curious and earnest i think the
the tic tac one is quite interesting and
made it in
major media recently but i don't know if
you ever saw the disclosure project
uh a guy named stephen greer organized
a bunch of mostly u.s military and some
commercial
flight people who had
direct observation and classified
information uh disclosing it at a cnn
briefing
and so you saw um high-ranking generals
admirals fighter pilots all describing
things that they saw
on radar with visual uh
with their own eyes or cameras and also
describing some
phenomena that had some consistency
across different
people and i find this interesting
enough that
i think it would be silly to just
dismiss it um
and specifically like we can we can ask
the question
how much of it is natural phenomena ball
lightning or something like that
and this is why i'm more interested in
what uh
fighter pilots and astronauts and people
who are trained in
um being able to
identify uh flying objects and um
atmospheric phenomena have to say about
it
i think the thing then you you could say
well are they
more advanced military craft um is it
some kind of you know human craft
the interesting thing that a number of
them describe is something that's kind
of like right angles
at speed or not right angles acute
angles at speed
but something that looks like a
different relationship to inertia than
physics makes sense
for us i don't think that there are any
human technologies that are doing that
even in really deep
uh underground black projects now
one could say okay well could it be a
hologram well would it show up on radar
if radar is also seeing it and
so uh i don't know i think there's
enough
i mean and for that to be a massive
coordinated psyop
is it as interesting and
ridiculous in a way as the idea that
it's ufos
from some extra planetary source so it's
it's up there on the interesting topics
to me there's if it is at all alien
technology
it is the dumbest version of alien
technology
it's so far away it's like the old old
crappy vhs tapes of alien technology
these are like crappy drones that just
floated or even like space
to the level of like space junk because
it is so close to our human technology
we talk about it moves in ways that's
that's unlike
what we understand about physics but it
still has very similar
kind of geometric notions
and something that we humans can
perceive with our eyes all those kinds
of things i feel like
alien technology most likely would be
something that
we would not be able to perceive not
because they're hiding but because it's
so far advanced
that it would be much
it would be beyond the cognitive
capabilities of us humans just as you
were saying
as per your answer for aliens
summarizing earth
it's uh the starting assumption is they
have similar perception
systems they have similar cognitive
capabilities and
that very well may not be the case
you